the opening scene features a high school
girl Aisha who is often troubled by
something within her body she is unable
to figure out what is wrong with her but
various stimuli trigger her leading her
to feel very uneasy as a result of this
she has been seeing her therapist Sharon
for several years one day Aisha goes
through her normal daily routine she
gets ready and goes to school with her
best friend Carrie there she also meets
with her boyfriend Levi who studies in
the same class during their physics
class a professor teaches them about
simatics a pattern forming process
through vibrational frequencies the
differing frequency of sounds makes
Aisha feel so uncomfortable that she
ends up discarding the devices later
that night Carrie tells Aisha about a
party that's going to start soon she
urges her to come with her boyfriend
Aisha obliges and goes to get Levi but
spots him using a service robot to
gratify himself this leaves her
disappointed again with the handyman
5000 so she storms away from there upon
arriving at the party she starts
drinking and dancing with one of her
classmates Caleb soon after she leads
the guy to a room in order to make out
with them but just before they can begin
Levi shows up and takes her away for a
private conversation he admits that he
received secret robotic codes so he
wanted to test them he also apologizes
for his actions but Aisha is so angry
that she ends their relationship in a
drunken State she walks into the
restroom where she accidentally trips
and falls as a consequence a glass
bottle in her hand shatters and one of
its pieces pierces her forearm despite
feeling excruciating pain she manages to
pull out the glass Shard only to witness
a shocking sight there are wires instead
of veins in her arms just then she's
disturbed by a high-pitched sound so she
grabs tweezers and puts it inside her
ears she then pulls out a long wire from
within this unsettling sight sets her
into a pen panic and she ends up
collapsing in the morning she awakens in
her room to discover numerous wounds on
her body but instead of blood she finds
wires and lights in it despite being
scared she somehow manages to regain
composure before heading to school when
she arrives she is approached by Carrie
who inquires about the previous night
however Aisha ignores her and rushes to
the bathroom to inspect her wound upon
closer examination she finds a metal
device with a serial number before she
can Del further though a classmate named
Jenny spots her wound leaving her
stunned she asks what's going on but
Aisha walks away without answering she
then approaches a college robot William
and shows him her wound hoping to get
some answers however the robot doesn't
disclose anything citing policy
restrictions terrified and Confused
Aisha goes to her therapist and confides
everything in her in a surprising twist
Sharon recites a code that deactivates
Aisha revealing that she is not not a
human but a robot Sharon then uses her
handheld device to Archive and erase all
of Aisha's memories from the past few
days in the next scene Aisha wakes up to
find no wounds which makes her believe
that it was all a dream with great
relief she arrives at school and goes to
talk to her best friend however Carrie
is mad at her because she tried to make
out with Caleb whom she likes Aisha who
has no recollection of this is obviously
perplexed by her friend's reaction
proceeding to the physics lab she meets
Jenny who appears somewhat scared of her
now Jenny asks about her well-being but
Aisha doesn't understand what she's
implying Jenny then activates a
highfrequency sound causing Aisha to
become extremely Disturbed she then
explains that only machines can hear
this level of sound this Revelation
freaks Aisha out so she rushes out of
the building only to run into William
she learns from him that they talked for
11 minutes the previous day upon
inquiring why she doesn't have any
recollection of this the robot bot
checks her before informing her that her
memory Drive was wiped 18 hours ago with
consent he helps her restore the erased
data reminding her of everything now
that she is unable to come to terms with
the horrifying truth Aisha storms away
from the scene she continues to run
until she reaches her geographical
limitation a point that she cannot cross
elsewhere we are introduced to Noah the
CEO of an advanced tech company called
rium Technologies he is currently
conducting an experiment on a naturally
deaf woman he administers a special drop
into her ear that surprisingly enables
her to hear for the first time this
makes the woman emotional and the
audience applauds Noah's success
meanwhile Aisha approaches Levi and asks
for the secret robotic codes he had been
using earlier despite initial reluctance
he eventually hands over the codes
following this she uses a library
computer to insert the code into her
system granting her access to all the
abilities possessed by a robot that this
newfound power allows her to read
people's minds and extract any
information she wants from them for the
first few moments she gets so excited
that she walks out and calls random
people by their names she then begins
testing the limits of what she's capable
of but the overwhelming memory load
causes her to collapse she regains her
Consciousness a while later and sees
that her father Martin has arrived to
take her back home once they head back
he tells her to get some rest while he
stays in the car to call Sharon sensing
some something am Miss Aisha activates
her enhanced hearing skill and Eaves
drops on their conversation she
shockingly learns that Martin is also
aware of her true nature after this he
goes to meet Sharon while the suspicious
Aisha begins investigating his room
Martin expresses concern for his
daughter but Sharon claims that she
can't control her anymore as Aisha has
hacked into her own system back at home
Aisha discovers a hidden tablet from
which she learns that her father is not
only surveilling her but also reading
reading her thoughts and even her facial
expressions the scene then cuts to four
years ago in Dallas where Martin met
Aisha for the first time at an event she
reminded him of his biological daughter
Cynthia whom he lost to salmonella
feeling a strange connection Martin
approached Aisha and started talking
with her it was at this moment she
introduced him to Sharon as her mother
their first meeting went so smoothly
that Martin started to visit them more
often over time a romantic relationship
developed between Martin and Sharon both
both of whom had experienced the loss of
their respective spouses despite this
she kept the secret of her daughter
being a robot one day Martin picked up
Aisha from school and took her for a
drive unaware of her geographical
limitations when Sharon learned of this
she hastily called him and instructed
him to pull over confused Martin
continued driving until Aisha's system
exhibited unusual behavior compelling
him to stop shortly after Sharon arrived
at the scene and recited a code to put
her into sleep mode she then dis closed
everything to Martin also confessing
that she hid it for Aisha's safety at
last she erased herself from the girl's
memory and reprogrammed herself as her
therapist back to the present Aisha
confronts Martin demanding answers he
then finally discloses that she was part
of a specialized project and Sharon was
the one to write her programs Martin
explains that they kept her hidden
because Rams are after her here it's
revealed that Sharon created Aisha for
the company but Noah rejected her
claiming that AI like Aisha are Beyond
regulation he also ordered her to shut
it down but she refused to do so as a
result she ran away with Aisha and kept
her hidden ever since armed with this
Revelation Aisha goes to Sharon and
demands the deactivation of all the
systems they use to Monitor and control
her when the latter hesitates she
threatens to expose her identity on
social media making her agree now with a
new sense of Liberty without
surveillance Aisha changes her get up
and proceeds to school with a noticeable
change in Attitude she no longer engages
in Friendly conversations with anyone
while wandering the school grounds she
suddenly spots Noah's Brother Abel
leading a school robot off the school
premises he then deactivates her system
and loads her into his van he also
checks William's database from which he
learns of Aisha's serial number sensing
potential danger Aisha quickly fleases
the scene shortly after she is
approached by Jenny who informs her
about the presence of a Tracker on her
feet Aisha inquires how she knows about
this to which the latter explains that
she used the same tracker to locate her
Jenny then assists her in removing the
tracker and leads her to an abandoned
place after this Jenny who has been
researching rium suggests that they
devise a proper plan to stay safe from
this tech company Aisha wonders why
she's been helping her to which Jenny
replies that they used to be close
friends but since her memory was wiped
out numerous times she forgot her
afterwards the the two friends go to
Levi and ask him to drive them to Canada
as they intend to meet Noah and prove
that Aisha deserves to exist on their
way Levi who is unaware of her secret
makes some offensive statements
regarding the robot which upsets her
after an entire day of driving they stop
by a motel to spend a night there the
following morning while Levi goes out to
get some coffee Aisha asks Jenny to hack
into her system and retrieve all erased
data from the very beginning Jenny
agrees and as the process initiates
Aisha begins regaining all of her
memories here it's revealed that Aisha
and Jenny became friends 3 years ago
from the present date as time passed
their relationship eventually turned
romantic and they started dating the two
were so in love with each other that
Aisha started to stand outside Jenny's
house at midnight waiting for her to
wake up this is how quick human brain
chemistry tells us to become stalkers
but when Martin and Sharon leared of
this they decided to wipe out her
memories as she wasn't really programmed
to handle affection or Obsession as a
result when she went to school the next
day she completely ignored Jenny and
befriended Carrie leaving her
heartbroken lover behind in addition
Aisha recollects how Noah and Abel
rejected her and canined her in a
basement store room during that time she
had a brother named Ken another AI robot
created by Sharon the siblings seemed to
have a deep bond and they promised not
to leave one another but one day their
promise was broken when Sharon came to
retrieve Aisha and escaped the company
for good overwhelmed by all of these
memories Aisha runs away from the motel
however she can't go much farther due to
low battery so she sits down on the side
of the road meanwhile Jenny and Levi
head out in search of their friend at
this point she finally discloses the
truth to him leaving him in shock he is
initially upset thinking that Aisha
fooled him but Jenny clarifies that she
wasn't aware of it either a short while
later they relocate Aisha and help her
charge her system while the two friends
leave her to get fully charged Abel
manages to track her down he then uses a
modern weapon to secretly deactivate her
before abducting her he drives her to
Noah in the rium headquarters but before
he hands her in Aisha somehow manages to
convince him to let her seek Ken as a
result he takes her to the basement and
activates Ken leading to a joyful
reunion between the siblings however
their happiness is shortlived as Noah
shows up and deactivates Cen he then
takes Aisha to his office where Martin
and Sharon are already waiting following
this Noah declares his decision to shut
down Aisha forever Martin and Sharon
attempt to explain that she poses no
threat to humanity and is different from
other robots but their pleas land on
deaf ears hearing the argument Aisha is
devastated on how they are controlling
her life in a fit of rage she storms out
of the room and makes her way to the
basement but before she can reach her
brother no Noah initiates the
termination process that slowly
deactivates her system as she collapses
to the ground Martin cradles her in his
lap and sobs while witnessing her die
subsequently both Ken and Aisha's bodies
are subjected to a grinding machine
crushing them into pieces in the
aftermath Martin and Sharon head back
home with sad Expressions on their faces
on the way they come across Jenny and
Levi who also break down in tears upon
learning of Aisha's tragic fate the
following day at school Jenny and Levi
stumble upon William who inquires about
Aisha mentioning that she has missed
three appointments with him when they
seek more details about the appointment
the robot asks for a password as the
files are encrypted Jenny then quickly
takes out Aisha's diary from her bag and
reads out several codes from it
fortunately one of the codes proves to
be correct which ultimately activates
Aisha's AI within Williams body it turns
out that she had previously uploaded a
backup of herself in Williams database
for safety reasons Aisha's return makes
her friends very happy and they all
Embrace each other on the other hand
Martin also receives a voice message
from Aisha who assures him that she will
come back to him once she finds a
correct body for herself elsewhere we
see that several artificial human
structures are being crafted with one of
them bearing a resemblance to Aisha
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching k